believe it or not there's a difference
between liberals and leftists and a lot
of people don't really differentiate and
i think it's because liberals and
leftists voted together yep and now that
trump's gone they're not going to
but here's you you hate to see it oh
these poor
young 20-something dsa types
a lot of these people who are democratic
socialists
this is their first foray into politics
they're in their early 20s you know
we've had some people here on the show
and you know i'll be talking to them and
i'll let these leftists and i'll say you
know look during the obama era you had
with occupy wall street blah blah i'll
say a bunch of things and they'll go i
was 10.
and i'm like
you were 10 years old like yeah so i
have no idea what that is i'm like okay
so they they come into this thinking
joe biden is their path towards getting
what they want not realizing that's not
true it's never been true it's been 50
years but they have no political
experience but they can't vote so what
do we get now over from cnbc student
debt forgiveness isn't in biden's annual
budget here's why experts say that's not
surprising well this expert says that's
not surprising because biden is
duplicitous and the democrats lie in
order to get elected not like
republicans don't but democrats do it so
all of these young dsa people thought
they were going to get student loan
forgiveness they were like we want fifty
thousand dollars and then biden was like
yeah okay we'll do it and they voted for
him and then he's like well we'll
probably just do ten thousand dollars
and then he's like now we're getting
nothing well by the way do these young
dsa types think that like cindy mccain
and all the establishment republicans
who couldn't vote for trump and were
voting for biden do you think they were
voting for that agenda
no no absolutely not this is this is not
surprising to anybody who's been paying
attention well we all know that bill
crystal's a huge fan of student debt
forgiveness right oh absolutely number
one issue like
and joe walsh and uh adam kinser and all
of these other rhinos they vote democrat
all the time because
conservatives became socialists or is it
because the establishment is the party
of the ultra wealthy and they're going
to sell you out to gain political power
and hey you don't gotta like trump but
at least trump was like a molotov
cocktail in the system well
by the way that's look i'm not i'm a fan
of bernie sanders and i'm a fan of
bernie sanders policies but the one
thing i appreciate about bernie sanders
is i actually think he believes in what
he says now i think most of that stuff
is completely insane but i respect the
fact that he actually will walk the walk
i don't think so i used to think that i
used to be a fan of bernie back in
2015-16 and then uh
i he just started flip-flopping you know
so he went up on stage the one of the
most famous moments and he said if
you're white you don't know what it's
like to be poor
okay that's a weird departure from where
bernie used to be when he was like
fighting for unions in the working class
now he's espousing woke garbage that
makes no sense and he endorsed hillary
clinton and i'm like ah okay he's got no
spine
you know bernie might might you know
believe these things but a jellyfish
with good ideas is still a jellyfish
then i'm not going to vote for it no and
i'm look i'm not saying the the dsa
types would have been disappointed with
bernie because bernie would have run a
campaign that would have been trying to
attract those suburban women voters who
just couldn't bring themselves to voting
for donald trump um which by the way i'm
proposing a constitutional amendment
that suburban women can no longer vote
yes
actually it would it would automatically
suburban women only suburban women it
would fix both both parties would be
fixed immediately so it's so it's not as
as as what is it the 19th it's not quite
yeah it's not as extreme as when people
say republicans
just if you're getting your political
opinions by watching bravo like if that
like and it's fine fine watch bravo but
if that if that's where you're getting
your political opinions from i think you
really shouldn't be voting
i mean
you know i i've been thinking about
quite a bit are you familiar with the
starship starship troopers so we we've
brought that up a lot service guarantees
citizenship and i used to be like no
people need to vote but the democrats go
too far with it right they want everyone
to be able to like sit in there sit in
their chairs eyes half open and then a
guy drops a letter on their on their
chest they go
they just stamp and then they hand it
back like there's got to be some effort
involved but now the more that i think
about it i'm like there's got to be some
skin in the game for voting because what
happens is people will move into you
know a city they'll live in new york new
york falls to crap so they'll move
somewhere where it's nice vote for crap
it falls to crap and then they leave
again you effectively have a group of
people that
act like you know they go from place to
place destroying it and then leaving and
then it's really difficult to repair
things politically
like most machines it's really easy to
break it's really hard to fix
well and fundamentally you'd think this
would be easy i mean if you're leaving
new jersey in new york because you hate
new jersey and new york i mean it's not
because you suddenly decided that you
can't stand the weather anymore or that
you you don't like the
corner deli it's because you hate the
way that the state's been run into the
ground
so yeah move to texas if you want but
don't vote for the same kind of
politicians
who ruined new york and that's what
we're seeing all across the the country
every one of these censuses where
they're showing like oh well north
carolina's adding people florida's
adding people georgia's adding people it
makes me nervous
because they're not moving from west
virginia
you know well people people are leaving
west virginia right yeah right yeah they
they lost a ton of uh is that a good
thing i think it might be a good thing
as long as it i mean i don't who are the
kind so so i read this story from i
think was the ap and it was like west
virginia saw the biggest exodus of any
state yes
and i was reading and people were saying
like i'm sick of being in this place
where they just want guns and i'm like
those people are leaving
that's good news though i'll say this
about west virginia and i told you i
live a mile from west virginia i walk
into west virginia from my backyard um i
think it's interesting when you find
these enclaves of like progressivism in
a place like west virginia they realize
they have to live with their neighbors
they realize that they're vastly
outnumbered
like conservatives are tolerant of
liberals that they disagree with you
know you go to harpers ferry you go to
berkeley springs you go to thomas west
virginia or davis there's all kinds of
little enclaves of progressivism
and it's completely and totally accepted
by the conservatives who run the state
yeah go to places like dc and try to
walk around with a make america great
again
hat on like it ain't gonna happen like
well this is this is actually a problem
conservatives have they the the
they're
unfortunately too tolerant yeah that's
and that's true the democrats will try
and claim that the republicans are
fascists and racist and i'm like
i don't know what you're talking about
like i see these memes from the left
where they're like republicans they'll
lie cheating steal to gain power and i'm
like they haven't had any power and how
long and they just don't do anything and
they won't do those things look nancy
pelosi will use whatever tools are
available to her even if they cross the
line even if they're an abusive power i
mean look her deciding to to strip the
committee assignments from marjory
taylor-greene for things that she said
not since she was in congress but things
she said before she got elected the
voters who elected her knew what she
said and the democrats decided to take
you know to strip her over committee
assignments if a republican did that
people be up and armed no republican
would ever do that what if a democrat
said offensive things while they were in
congress like i don't know ilhan omar
ilhan omar or maxine waters who's been
pushing crazy conspiracy theories for
decades republicans are are too weak man
the republican politicians they're
they're
i remember who said this but they're
more concerned about the opinion of the
new york times than they are of their
own constituents absolutely so what
happens is nancy pelosi shrieks and her
hair stands on end like she's like
floating around like a banshee and
everyone's just like you know terrified
and then when ilhan omar does something
she calms down and well you know let's
be reasonable and republicans are like
that's not fair anyway
is that is that it there's no screech
screeching banshees on the republican
side we're going to float around and
scream
so well again it's and by the way this
was this was a i love president trump
but this was a trump fault you you hit
the nail on the head too many
republicans care about what the new york
times says about them it's like trump
would be talking to maggie haberman at
the new york times yep and i'm like why
are you talking to maggie hey
she hates you pathologically she
despises you she will never write a good
story about you it's and yet he still
would because he wanted
to see that good story it's like sad
cringe it's like it is these uh
these republicans
are desperate to be accepted by the
establishment political class
so they they bag the new york times i
know you're woke but i'll pretend to be
woke a little bit not all of them
there's a handful of good ones so we
recently saw thomas massey marjory
taylor green they refused to wear masks
nancy pelosi fined margaret taylor green
500 bucks then 2 500 bucks yet she's on
video in the white house with no mask on
hugging people and everyone nobody's
wearing master all partying
this is the problem the democrats have
double standards if they didn't have
double standards they have none at all
and the republicans don't do anything no
no absolutely speed bumps for democrats
absolutely and by the way look when i
heard pelosi give her explanation for
why that she was not going to remove the
mass mandate she said it's you know a
question of the honor system and am i
just going to trust that these people
have gotten vaccinated here's the thing
you don't have to worry the cdc said if
you've gotten vaccinated you don't have
to worry about unvaccinated people so
here's nancy pelosi standing there
saying something that contradicts her
you know the science the science of all
these people talking about we gotta
follow the science follow the science
again if trump had said something like
that it would be non-stop coverage for
three days about how trump is ignoring
the science nancy pelosi says it and the
media just brushes it off there was a
study done in france and uh techcrunch
wrote about it it was this little-known
drug called hydroxychloroquine and trump
just passively said the study is looking
very great you know it's looking good
maybe we'll see something and the media
went nuts donald trump is recommending
medicine oh no people are gonna die
bro there's people outside of 7-elevens
giving vaccines and i'm like
hold on man if you're going to undergo
any kind of medical procedure i'll be at
a minor one like a vaccine go to your
doctor first because
you know i was reading about some kid
who had had an allergic reaction or
something or was like you know was told
by his doctor he'd be like be careful i
forgot what it was something with eggs i
don't know
and uh
there's there's there's a video where
like these army guys walk in with
7-eleven and then just like give the guy
behind the counter a vaccine and i'm
like
you were complaining about donald trump
talking about news from techcrunch and
now this is going on can't you just say
vaccines are great go talk to your
doctor to figure out what's best for you
they don't do that they they will smear
trump and attack him in the most extreme
ways and claim trump said to inject
bleach in your veins and then they'll
and then they'll come out and like do
the exact opposite we don't got fighters
though man no we don't and by the way we
we never have and and the only good side
of that is that's how we ended up with
trump we ended up with trump because
after decades of not having fighters the
base said
okay who's the one candidate that they
won't they don't want us to vote for
trump
that's the guy that they all hate so
we're going to give them the one guy
they say we can't vote for do you
remember the michael moore speech from
2016 which one was that so michael
moore's speech he said that
you know donald trump walks into these
auto manufacturers and he says if you
move your cars overseas i will i will
tax you 30 percent and no one will ever
buy your car again and the people of
michigan heard that and that's the first
time anyone ever stood up to these
companies
and so people they saw trump you know
now not paraphrasing that people saw
trump as the biggest fu to the
establishment a human molotov cocktail
be thrown in the system and he was
and the system boy did they react they
they flipped out look i always tell
people i voted for trump there's a lot
of policy things that i voted for trump
based on but even bigger than that i
voted for him to be the wrecking ball
taken to the system like and he
accomplished it in spades he completely
and totally exposed the media he exposed
the establishment of the republican
party he exposed the dirty way that
politics has been played in this country
for decades and decades and decades and
we're never going to go back
like the the base of the republican
party that voted for trump trump led all
the monkeys out of our cages and they're
never going to be able to put us back
again thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to see the full show come back to
this channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time